good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday Tuesday
this week is just crawling ma-ya and
feels here today so I thought it might
be Wednesday cuz that's the O's day hump
day but nope it's Tuesday didn't mean to
alarm anyone it's just I took a nap
yesterday so I feel like it was really
two days yesterday yeah yesterday was a
long one I just feel as though this week
is gonna be a long one as well but we
have to see a drawer I hear crunchy
angel Dora la vie man Dora Juan & only
Dora my whole heart
Dora love of my life Dora beautiful boy
Dora soft and sweet Dora delicious lips
Dora nutritious lips Dora superstitious
hips Dora current she angel duh yes bo
is in studio today and that means we're
gonna have a great show we're gonna be
filled with this time and joy and
uniqueness nerve and talent because he
is here and he just gives us he like you
know what a Jenna sit quiet like some
people are like the morning toast that's
what it is about that show I just like
feel like I relate to these girls and I
relate to the show and like you know I
could be going through a tough time but
like the morning toast allows me to just
forget about that for 30 minutes to an
hour closer to 30 minutes these days
literally I was actually thinking
yesterday was like some days are longer
than others because if we have TV recap
and yesterday we had um movie of the
week recap and I'm a position was still
37 minutes long like and when we were
done I'm like damn that was an hour we
used to like roll off with our episodes
but just there's so little news it's a
combination of things first of all we
used to have like active vibrant busy
lives and we would sit for at least ten
minutes before we got into the news and
just talk about like where we went to
dinner last night something funny that
happened to us without even like
planning it we just like always had
something to share yeah um here's
something funny that happened to me
yesterday I fell asleep and I woke up
sweating like say I took a nap and I
woke up in a deep sweat meet you dun dun
literally I had the same exact
experience also like the stories were
more robust pre Q because the
celebrities were having similar
experiences going to dinner
ya know having vibrant life making
relationships yeah and then also yeah
there was just like no buffer stuff when
we all were like living the life of
Riley and now it's just like here's the
news and it's pretty sad yeah most of
the news is really sad and at the end of
the day like of course we have to report
on it but there's not much to say with
like sad stories and it's like I've in
the last week I feel like five or six
celebrities have passed away like it's
so many people and those stories are
just so hard to report on and some most
of the time there's really nothing to
say other than the fact that we're just
like devastated so our episodes through
really no fault of our own have been
super short but let's try to make this
one day it is because they're
expeditious and we do cut to the chase
you know and we say what we need to say
we're so expeditious we're so
expeditious and maybe it would behoove
us to be a little more lackadaisical in
our talking and our thinking also if we
spoke at a normal speed our episodes
would be 60 to 75 minutes but that's
just not our fault because we were born
this way baby you know what we've tried
that and that's just not who we are it's
not who we are ever going to be but I
can't believe like we didn't just jump
into this immediately because something
really exciting did happen to us
yesterday we made the unbelievable
discovery that not only are the people
at Sports Illustrated but mjj herself
fans of the morning toast because they
listened to her episode and they loved -
we had to say and they were like
commenting on our Instagram and it was I
was joking when I said yesterday that I
was disappointed that it wasn't me on
the cover but you never know 2021 could
be my year yeah and you know what like I
really do feel as though if you wanted
to like you could apply for the swim
search and you could get in the magazine
for 2021 like why not you I feel like
they do cool stuff influencer
integration all the time you're such a
role model thank you and you're so badiy
positive I'm so buddy positive and I
just feel like if that's what you wanted
you can make it happen the thing is it's
not really what I want like I don't want
to be in a bathing suit like
professionally but at the end of the day
if the opportunity arises like I would
of course take the opportunity it's just
like on my list of things like bikini
model is really not super high up but
again I'll take the opportunity yeah
you just have to say yes to life and
when Jay calls you and so when MJ calls
I answer speaking of saying against
opportunities to life been yesterday
made the decision to sign us both up for
American Idol auditions because they're
being done remotely so you don't have to
stand in line you could send in a video
that's nice and I was shocked to learn
when I got the email like to finish my
my video upload that you know you have
to be 17 to audition for American Idol
and you can't be older than 28
interesting so ageist as spokesperson
for ageism how do you feel about that
I'm sure they have their reasons and I'd
be interested in hearing the reasoning
how old was Taylor Hicks uh heat well he
was graying early so that's not yeah but
still what's he graying at 21 like he
was grating in his 20s for sure okay 20
29 29 oh so they definitely move the age
down down I'm just saying and it's a
little I'm not gonna finish the tryouts
I don't I don't think that my life isn't
gonna happen that way like I have I have
a pretty good idea of how my life is
gonna plan out roadmap wise and it's
just I'm not gonna win American Idol I
just don't think that's what's gonna
happen
well man plans God laughs whoo no that's
true beyond that stage singing your song
make a plan oh God make a plan okay I'm
planning right make a man planning in my
head need to play with you boys your
head can use a planner I would not these
days my planners empty oh my god okay in
my head
whatever you were in the truck I'm not
gonna do it anymore well you have to
like God also [ __ ] with your plans in
your head not just the ones on your
planner yeah but we're on like this
visual show but I thought it would be
the commonest it's a podcast it's it's a
web show don't don't insult icarly it's
also a podcast it's a web show it's
mostly a podcast that is true actually
or is someone once called it a little
Instagram show which was so sweet but
unfortunately we no longer fit that
criteria you guys memory used to live
stream on Facebook and Instagram
yep those were the days so many
platforms so little time yeah we were
figuring it out now we've got it down to
a science
we've got it down to a science um okay I
guess we could get into it now yes well
we have fabulous Fast Five and we have
some Kelley's mindless news which I'm so
excited about so it's exciting it's
gonna be hard for me not to like rush
through to the end because you're
actually of all the mindless news I love
choosing the mindless news stories it's
some of the most it's the most
gratifying part of my job I would say
and today's story in particular has to
be one of the most absurd like it's
insanity really crazier than the porch
that was literally it's on the same
level it's the same type of story okay
okay I think I might like now people
tagged me and kmn I'm so I don't want
like Haman spoilers because I love when
you share like the news that I never I
had to see in order to believe and
what's also so you know full circle
about the kmn story is that it's from
AOL comm which used to host our show
until they fired us so it's just really
it's nice to to make a full circle
moment you know hey well I'm excited to
see like what I love a comm is pushing
hurricane yeah no I look it's nice to
see what they're up to since they let go
of two of their biggest stars biggest
and brightest stars yeah okay well I
think without further ado it is time for
the Fast Five story is that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast you in case
you don't think that it's you it's it's
you yet if you're like sitting there
like it's not me yeah it's you know I
find that a lot of people sit there and
think it's not me but it is you it's you
it's you it's you guys it's you so I'm
ready I'm ready too okay we have a lot
of big stories about like follow-ups
developments but unfortunately Naya
Rivera is body was recovered on the
7-year anniversary of Cory Monteith's
death spooky the discovery of my aware
of my Rivera's body early Monday in a
California Lake
tragically coincides with the
anniversary of her Glee co-star Cory
Monteith's death Rivera's body was
pulled from the waters of Lake Piru
about 56 miles northwest of downtown Los
Angeles exactly seven years after
Monteith died of a drug overdose so um
the details have emerged about what the
police think might have happened right
they talked with her son yeah and they
said that she quote mustered enough
energy to get her son on the boat but
not enough to save herself oh my god
Naya Rivera spinal moments were spent
saving the person she loved most
according to investigators on Monday the
former Glee star's body was found five
days after she went missing during a
boating trip at Lake Piru in Ventura
County with her four-year-old son Josie
at a news
prints on Monday afternoon Ventura
County Sheriff Bill a you but recounted
what her son told authorities about the
tragic accident quote we know from
speaking with her son that he and nya
swam in the lake together at some point
during their journey it was during that
time that her son described being helped
into the boat by Naya who boosted him
onto the deck from behind he told
investigators that he looked back and
saw her disappear under the surface of
the water
wow that's by the way that's so tragic
like to be in the presence of like of
the moment like it's just this child is
I'm so glad he's okay and like Shania is
an amazing mom and like she made chair
she's made sure and like it's just it's
such a terrible story and like the more
we learn about it the more devastating
and tragic that it is and just the more
you like neither of air like was a big
star but like she's been kind of low-key
like since Scalise stopped airing and
you didn't really know that much about
her and just seeing all these people
share their moments with her like Becca
Tobin shared such a nice all the Glee
cast Leake has said the nicest things
about her just that she was just this
bright star someone who could make you
feel like you were so important and
someone I'm so nice but like what we
know about her is her character Santana
who was an iconic meme cheerleader but
she obviously wasn't really like that so
it was just cool to like see all these
people sharing behind the scenes clean
moments and just like pictures and
memories that I found to be really
endearing and the connection of this
also being on the day where Cory
Monteith had tragically passed away as
well like this is a little too spooky
for me
yeah I can't think too much about it it
is pretty spooky I'm glad that her
family has peace now and that they're
getting some answers yeah but this is
just a terribly tragic story and
following up on something I said
yesterday which is the media's inability
to give people space there were
paparazzi pictures of coroner the
coroner pulling um it was in a her body
was in a bag but there were pictures of
them pulling her out of the lake where
do you see these pictures Twitter oh
it's it's so [ __ ] insane and
disrespectful and then it reminded me
where like we saw a picture of Jeffrey
Epstein's body well you really only saw
his ear when he was pulled out of the
prison where he quote/unquote committed
suicide but like he's a disgrace to
humanitarian no sorry I just greatest
human he he's not a humanitarian he's a
disgrace human he does not deserve the
right
to privacy or that type of respect but
Naya Rivera like this is such a tragedy
and she was just like she was just a mom
you know like incredibly I never cease
to be let down and disappointed by like
the lanes that the media will go yeah
that's that's sick once again I hit
second and I didn't know major
publications like aren't posting photos
like that but the fact that there's even
people taking them that means that
there's someone there's a demand for it
yeah it's someone asked for it exactly
it's so upsetting like it's so wrong and
I don't it didn't say who but a bunch of
the Glee cast members got together like
on a dock by like Pete Lake Piru and I
guess just like held a moment of silence
which was really sweet I mean there's a
lot going on in the Glee fandom
especially as it pertains to Lea Michele
because she deleted her twitter she
deleted her twitter I read online it was
because people were like bullying her on
Twitter I mean bullying her on Twitter
um about what's going on with niya
because there been rumors for years that
um her and niya
did not get along on the set of Glee
especially towards the end and niya
wrote a book which actually I would be
really interested to read apparently was
really juicy and it had some stuff about
Lea Michele in there so I'd be curious
to hear what it said but Lea Michele is
just like not having a good month yeah
no she's not but she's pregnant so right
that's exciting for her I hope she's
just not causing too much stress that's
not good I actually just was looking at
her Instagram and she's like so pregnant
so pregnant yeah so I guess it's a happy
time for her regardless I guess yeah um
anyways another very very sad story a 24
year old youtube star Nicole Thea dies
along with her unborn child what the
[ __ ] the london-based influencers family
confirmed the news on Sunday in an
Instagram post stating that Thea's
unborn son had also died quote to all
Nicole's friends and supporters it is
with great sadness that I have to inform
you that Nicole and her son she and boga
named rain sadly passed away on Saturday
morning the statement read the message
the message explained that Thea had
pre-scheduled a few youtube videos to
upload on her channel before her death
and her boyfriend boga had made the
decision to allow them to be aired the
family asked for privacy saying our
hearts are truly broken and we are
struggling to cope with what has
happened the cause of Thea's death is
not yet known the former dancer was
around
it's pregnant oh my god what like when I
heard this story I'm like what what
could happen this year that like would
surprise me like this is so tragic so
insane to be so young and to die so
young and then to die when you're also
so young and pregnant eight months
pregnant that's just awful awful
terrible stories right just gives you a
pit in your stomach yeah um I just I
can't even imagine this is one of those
stories there's just there's really
nothing to say it's absolutely horrible
so tragic and really just thinking and
praying for her family I mean two losses
in one it's just it's horrible yeah
that's really terrible you're not
getting pulled over there's some drama
behind us please - we're getting pulled
over yeah oh we haven't had a siren and
I'm not gonna lie I could've missed it
like when we were on zoom it was so much
less exciting I hope everyone's okay
that's how I'm scanning pretty close
yeah we can mute ourselves
[Music]
sorry about that you guys today's
episode before we dive into the next
story I just want to remind you was
brought to you by health code you want
to eat healthy but you probably don't
have the time maybe they're not the
budget or the know-how right you'll love
what we just discovered an easy
delicious perfectly nutritious and
superstitious meal replacement shake
from health code it gives you exactly
what your body needs for weight
management and your overall health if
you've tried other things it's
incredible that you can get it all in
one shake you can save money and feel
better and you can now get a special
offer at get health calm which is GE t h
LT h dot-com and use the code toast for
a special offer at get health GE t HL th
comm code toast health code wasn't
created by a celebrity it was formulated
by an actual scientist who specializes
in metabolism and nutrition you want to
lose you want to lose fat but want to
keep lean muscle mass that's why they've
included 27 grams of the best quality
protein including collagen for healthy
hair skin and nails you need a healthy
gut so health code complete meal has
probiotics digestive enzymes prebiotic
fiber and apple cider vinegar
it also has 25 vitamins and minerals
plus healthy fats for a healthy brain
and metabolism it only has 4 grams of
carbs so it is keto season friendly
which is why when we got our box I gave
an entire package to man because he's
constantly on the hunt hunt for keto
friendly options it's also natural and
has no GMOs or artificial junk zero
added sugar and it tastes amazing it's
very satisfying and it keeps us full for
hours both flavors taste really good the
shake is available in two flavors
chocolate macadamia and creamy vanilla
Ben likes our creamy vanilla better if
you want to get a special offer again
the link is get health.com GE THL th com
just use the discount code toast for an
extra 10% off your first order they also
have a love it or your money back
guarantee but this offer is only
available for a limited time so go to
get health get HL th comm using the
discount code toast to check it out love
it sign on get health sign on it help
okay
next story it's a big story out there
right now Will Smith's marriage ain't
for the weak at heart how he and Jada
pinkett-smith
reunited after their split okay Will
Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith are giving
a candid look at the ups and downs in
their marriage after the actress
confirms she had a romantic relationship
well she confirms she had an
entanglement yes she was being very
roundabout circling the drain with her
verbiage with singer August Alsina while
they had been briefly separated he like
came out and said like I'm in a
relationship with Jada I was in a
relationship and the world was shook by
it and they went to the red tabletalk
but they said they were planning on
ignoring it like that like they have
been people have spoken about them for
years there have been very many rumors
that they have some sort of like
arrangement in their marriage where it's
an open relationship where it's like
they're very much in love they're very
much married partners but they also see
other people which if that's the case
that's totally fine everyone does what
they have to do to get through but they
actually denied that on their show which
I thought was really impressive because
you know they're big stars they don't
have to address all this like drama so
they don't have to adjust the drama but
considering this is now Jada's job where
she addresses other people's drug addict
rumors in headlines I don't know how she
could do the next read table talk not
having addresses at all considering it's
true right now that's true it is her job
that we're completely false
they don't have to address it it doesn't
matter like people are gonna talk and
hate nerds are gonna hate but she told
us it's it's true yeah he wasn't lying
well he wasn't lying but they did have
like an explanation which the
explanation was basically well Smith and
Jada said that like when they when
August and Jada were in this
relationship it was during a time when
Will and Jada were five they were
separated they were like thinking about
getting divorce but the marriage is over
they were not together we're not
together which makes a lot of sense
obviously um which is okay so here's the
conversation was like so awkward it was
but then you can also tell like they
like they said their ride-or-die they
have each other's backs I don't I don't
know if this is the whole truth but it's
it works one of it's what they felt
comfortable sharing and it also works
for the people who are like Will and
Jada
royalty couple forever you know and
there's also people who read the lines
and are like they have an open
relationship there's you know when yours
is being thrown around yeah and so I
think that the read Table Talk um for me
I didn't need it I don't care what you
do and if you sup with someone else like
I really don't care I totally agree like
life it's your marriage whether you were
together at the time or separated again
it's not my business and I and I don't
care so I didn't need it but I feel like
people who really believe in their in
their marriage know people who like
idolize them as a couple I get that but
at the same time like I I get that we
live in this world where we feel like
celebrities don't have a right to any
privacy and like I guess in some ways I
subscribe to that notion like I'm
obsessed with celebrity culture but
there are certain things where I feel
like people just don't owe us an
explanation and this is one of those
things it's like this is such a private
matter like guess we know them as a
couple but at the end of the day like
certain things can and should be private
and they don't feel like I'm owed like
an explanation or an apology for what
goes on between two people in their
marriage you know what I mean yeah I
don't feel like I need that either but I
guess other people feel that way and
they felt the need to speak on it and I
feel like what they said suffice is in
terms of like still being able to ship
them and you know see them as like this
institution yeah as Karen would here say
their marriage is an institution which
it is in Hollywood being married for 20
years is no small feat none at all and I
agree like people and maybe this is like
part of why they've stayed successful
and relevant for so long is a because
they both work a lot but because people
just really love them in their family
and maybe like for business wise like
they didn't want she just not address
the rumors because like I said so many
people look up to him and so much like a
part of their brand it's like their
successful marriage in Hollywood so
maybe addressing it it's just like good
for business oh it is good for business
because this was the most watched
Facebook watch video abuse yeah that was
insane yeah
so I'm sure she did really well from it
I'm sure it was great for the table hmm
um and the talk I actually loved read
Table Talk and I loved the concept of it
and I feel like every time I watch an
episode they totally changed my mind on
a subject even the Jordan Woods thing
like I think they they let her off a
little easy but at the same time like
Jada made a really good point she was
just like you know your 21 year old girl
who like kiss the wrong boy
yep that happens to plenty of people and
their lives don't get ruined because of
it right it's almost like the anti
cancellation table like yes but they
offer different bull so it's her
daughter her and her mom so it's like
three generations through totally
different perspectives which i think is
like such a unique refreshing type of
content yeah you know I agree but I feel
like there was one that I just can't
remember that she did that was really
impactful as well it's a great great
Chuck it's a great premise and I don't
think she could continue doing and if
she didn't address the rumors that
turned out to be true right so I'm happy
for them I'm happy for the stand is that
that everyone has like their explanation
can put a bow on it very great with that
until I just admit that it was true
right everyone hopefully got what they
needed at the end of the day I'm glad
they addressed it because it was getting
so messy for a while but like August was
like speaking on Jada and like no one
was responding and it was just like
they're like to me like Jada and Will
are like so above this so I'm glad like
that we're beyond this now you know yeah
it's it's done no they really are but
it's always nice to see like real a list
celebrities in you know web show format
like you love to see it or on the
podcast like it is very exciting you do
get to see them like you've never seen
them before yeah and so overall it was
enjoyable and I'm glad that they're good
and good for them for just squashing it
yeah it was a little awkward in the
beginning like you could feel the
tension liked it but but it's also
edited yeah they get to the point pretty
quickly it was it was good I think it
was the right PR move whoever's
instructing them is obviously in tune
with what's necessary yes definitely
okay next story speaking of talking
Tamera Mowry
exits the real after seven years crazy
first um she announced on Monday that
she is leaving the real after six season
she said quote for seven years my home
in heart has been at the real the
friendship said I've made there will
last a lifetime and the people that I've
had the blessing to interview have
changed my life for the better
mari added she is so proud of what the
cast has accomplished including two
well-deserved n-double-a-cp Image Awards
and a daytime Everitt Emmy however all
good things must come to an end it's
with a bittersweet smile that I announce
that I'm moving on from the real to my
fellow hosts I love you I will miss you
and I will always be there for you thank
you for teaching me supporting me and
loving all of me
she said she'll be routing from her cast
for her cast mates from afar you know
what like if this was me and I had like
a gig on a daytime show that was like on
a network really popular I made a lot of
money like I would never leave
yeah well this just makes a question
like where's she going cuz it seems like
a great gig she's happy she loves her
fellow hoes and literally every host in
America is gonna be like vying to be her
replacement so it leaves two questions
one where's she going to who's gonna
take her spot well so can you remind me
who are the other co-hosts currently on
the reel I know Loni love is yes
literally my favorite person have you
ever seen her on Worst Cooks in America
it was one of the funniest things I've
ever seen in my life Adrienne Bailon hmm
oh Jenny May yep and then Tamar Braxton
but she left it in 2016
oh okay Amanda steals oh um it's it'll
be really interesting to see who they
give this spot to because it's really
coveted people don't just leave jobs
like that and when they do it's like
everyone wants it so I'm curious eh why
she left even though it seems amicable I
don't think there's any drama I just she
might have gotten like a even a better
gig somewhere else would you fighting to
hear where she goes right but if she
doesn't like I just can't imagine I mean
I get seven years is a long time and
like maybe she's like made enough money
where she just wants like be with her
kids which I totally get sometimes you
just outgrow a thing like to wake up and
do the same thing every day for seven
years like you need to be challenged and
excited yeah it might excite her and so
right she might use excited by the
excitement I feel that yeah so sometimes
you just need to switch it up yeah well
I'll be so curious to see who they
replaced her with yeah so many good
options you know I hope they digging
more into the digital space that's just
always a good look for us that's very
true honestly Rachel Lindsay I mean
she's so busy so busy and honestly I
don't think she would move I think they
film in LA I don't know if she would
move to LA and she has so much going on
but she would be fabulous she would but
I truly think she's too busy me too
okay ready for our cut the final story
cuz it's a little business it's some
it's some exciting business yeah I would
say Zappos is now selling single shoes
and mixed size pairs right now by us
sandal or sneaker from Zappos or even
mixed size pairs of running shoes it's
part of a push by the online retailer to
cater to shoppers who naturally have
different sized feet as well as those
with prosthetics which can create a need
for mix sized shoes
initially Zappos which is owned by
Amazon will offer the option for six
brands nike billy footwear converse plae
stride right and New Balance the shoes
will be available beginning Tuesday in
all sizes and widths from toddler to
adult and they range in price from $17
to $85 changhie
say it again the plae know the name of
the brand with Zappos zappy were
literally being Australian okay I didn't
realize that this was a thing I think
the next step is obviously we need to
start selling bras with two different
size cuffs because that is a real
problem but I didn't know the difference
I suppose I mean it makes a lot of sense
some people might have naturally I have
like one foot that's like a tiny bit
fatter but for the most part like I fit
into the shoes just fine but I didn't
think about like prosthetics it's
obviously a huge market it's very
exciting it's very inclusive and I think
it's a great thing like if you or if you
don't even if you don't have a
prosthetic like one of those models has
one leg so obviously you would need one
shoe I didn't even think of that yeah
exactly so now you can buy a single shoe
or if you have a if you have a pair of
shoes and you lose one that's what I
thought but it's another added benefit
now you can add a single shoe
interesting you know I never thought
that like this this was like the next
frontier in the shoe English industry
but I see the great move from Zappos I'm
a big fan of Zappos because they have a
fabulous theater in Vegas that we were
gonna see Kelly Clarkson at but we had
to get a refund for our tickets because
of [ __ ] coronavirus yeah and cuz one
time they sent me a gift card and it was
like I got so much stuff and it was so
great well I order like site actually
Zappos is a fabulous I'm saying it like
you know Zappos Zappos they have
fabulous commercials with like the
beautiful neighborhoods where like the
boxes are just like showing up on
people's porches it's fabulous it is
really fabulous so I think this is a
great move by a fabulous brand I just
wanted to highlight it because that's
what we do here at the morning toast and
it's been a while since we had a little
business and it just feels good to to
say that and
step back into the business world you
know because we're so highly respected
and revered and I think our colleagues
in the business world were like hey what
about us no I mean I don't know if
everyone remembers maybe I should never
mind like I was on CNBC once at the
stock market and people say it's one of
the most iconic segments ever done
that's what they say but I don't know if
I definitely the most iconic seventeen
I've ever watched him squawk alley it is
also the only segment I've ever watched
him squawk alleys how what is called
squawk alley literally when I was down
there like I was down there for the
month snapchat went public like they
were just like looking for like young
people to talk about it and I was in
hair and makeup and I literally remember
googling like what does IPO stand for
because they told me they weren't gonna
like talk about like so much financee
stuff but I didn't want to be they just
wanted to talk about the platform like
do we like snapchat is it worth good
money you know like you're informing
them like based on what how you feel
about snapchat you're informing like
this IPO worth it what do the children
actually but I didn't even know what IPO
meant like I know that public just
basically meant like Miranda and her
husband were making a lot of money
Miranda Kerr yeah but I didn't know like
now I'm like because of his news I'm
obviously like so well-versed you know
it's an initial public offering courses
years ago and it was $27 a share and I
did recommend to the audience that they
not buy it and so far I've been totally
right I was gonna say I would love to
watch the segments just to see if your
advice was correct or your speculation
because I think we all know where
snapchat went except oh my god um there
is a new what snapchat show like I
actually might Ricky and Denzel I
literally might down trailer yesterday I
thought the exact same thing it looks so
[ __ ] good so obviously everyone knows
Ricky and his crazy hilarious videos and
Denzel is his best friend who I met on a
like a branded trip in Vegas real world
the real world he was literally one of
the funniest coolest everything he wore
was Dior like mint did you or he was so
funny and him and right here like this
hilarious duo and they have a show now
on snapchat workspace if we like the
simple life that's what / was getting as
well they're going in doing let these
crazy odd jobs and they're both so funny
like I actually might download snapchat
to watch it I was thinking the same
thing I actually used snapchat a lot um
now that I realize it because American
campers on snapchat and she's always
just snapping counselors management so I
already have snapchat and
maybe it's on its way back up I don't
think so
okay sore and no done by snap no don't
buy snap obviously I don't really have a
say like maybe you should buy smash like
cuz of Ricky's show right and obviously
it's pretty low right now so it can
really only go up yeah um okay now I
want to kill these mindless news I don't
know why I took my cards because it's
here Gillies mindless news like the
fourth of July you are going to plots
from this story okay it's from AOL hmm
Kelly Ripa gives us a rare look inside
her home in new IG post so if you were
to imagine what this photo looks like oh
no what if she's giving us a rare look
into her home and a new IG post I'm
expecting actually a video home tour is
what I'm expecting that's what that
headline warns because they also said I
G post not IG photo so I'm expecting a
video if we're gonna get an unseen look
okay at home so that's not what we got
actually we got a a selfie of her and
Mark with a wall behind them literally
with one frame I will show you the
picture we will post this on our
Instagram this is the inside peek at her
home lying there's this it's a carousel
key but yeah her and her son you're in
the doorway knows it that can't be no
that's it let me general
can I please curl and make sure there's
no additional photos I think anything
I'm talking [ __ ] don't believe you
there's no arrow no scroll up and down
the article there's no additional photos
with an inside look in her home no okay
ready
there's so many ads on AOL's are calm
okay ready Kelly Ripa is giving her
followers another glimpse into her
family home while Simon while
simultaneously supporting mixed martial
arts on Tuesday the live with Kelly and
Ryan co-host shared a slideshow of
photos of herself her hubby Maher
Consuelos and her son Joaquin sporting
matching six-gun t-shirts gifted to her
by world-renowned MMA striking coach
Brandon Gibson and while we'd love to
see the ribbon gang promoting fitness we
couldn't help but take a peek behind
Kelly and Mark to admire their wall
decor
I can't wait to pose this picture
because the blank wall no that's not
even that Kelly and Mark are
whole picture I would say probably one
inch of the photo you could see the wall
guys now I'm actually like Kelly's my
masseuse has always been like fun and
funny but now I'm concerned like I think
there's something they're not telling to
say this is a deeper conspiracy theory
of like I don't know maybe like Kelly
like needs to get her a google search
like change something up and so like she
just feeds these [ __ ] stories but
like you guys she's not even showing her
weight here writing this is while we own
while we only have a small glimpse we
are able to see a lamp no but here's a
lamp a few pieces of art not true and
even part of an indoor plant this is
insane the headlines is a rare glitter
waale art features a depiction of a
woman or a stick figure
while another piece seems to match but
instead includes an entire family oh and
did we mention we are also loving this
seafoam colored wall okay it's literally
beige I don't know what they're talking
about there's something going on here
I'm differencing I'm sure of it I've
never been so sure of anything this is
not a new story the headline doesn't
like I don't know if a oels outcome is
going through a hard time or if Kelly is
going like I don't know I'm gonna
suggest the latter I don't know where
the cover-up is coming from but it's
coming it's coming this is so insane I I
could not believe in Kelly's mindless
news anymore it's Kelly's cover up my
list lies it's Kelly's mindless lies
can't leave my list cover no it's just
why why are we working so hard to write
up articles about Kelly Ripa what what's
on the other side of this what what are
we hiding what are we covering up your
attention to like they're actually
making it worse for her because the more
mindless the news is and you know what
this is actually an insult to mindless
news because we love mindless news their
love looks like mindless news just like
a celebrity commenting on another
celebrity's Instagram it's just a staple
of celebrity culture as the mindless
news and it's a symbol of the morning
toast show and so went out for some iced
coffees sickening love the mindless news
this is a whole new thing no this one is
actually this might be crazier than the
porch because in terms of square footage
we actually did see like a rug and one
chair and there were two a lie there
this is a [ __ ] bald-faced lie and
it's insanity and I cannot wait to post
it on our Instagram you guys it's not
sane you think we're being crazy but
we're not we I'm this episode is up like
we'll get that picture up stat so right
now you need to go to re-enter and look
at it because it is there and it ain't
right it ain't right and we were just
that's what we do here at the morning
shows we point out things that ain't
right yeah that is exactly what we did
and Kelly's mindless news is absolutely
no exception
and Kelly's mindless news dare I say
it's becoming the backbone of the show
no it is like I feel as though we've
kind of stumbled like obviously it
started out as a funny thing like we you
know she obviously has a good
relationship with People magazine right
it was meant to be a joke
it was meant to be a joke but now like
it's something so much deeper we are I
think about to uncover one of the
biggest conspiracy theories in Hollywood
I'm 100% sure about it I think some
that's the name of today's episode
something they write something ain't you
saw that
it smells fishy okay smells like a
cover-up smells like a lie Kelly's -
laughs like a cover-up and not the one
that she's been wearing - hosts live
with Kelly and Ryan but you know what
you won't believe what it looks like you
know insanity you guys I'm so glad we
got that until that Theo was here for
that because he needs to see the
difference no he is a mint like he's
constantly in the media and so he knows
like what that kind of life is like but
you know he tries not to let it get to
him but I think this is something he
might actually want to know about I
think so - you you definitely want to
know the truth um is there anything else
we want to talk about before we wrap it
up um no I didn't watch anything
yesterday because I started a fabulous
new book last night that I literally
almost finished in one sitting I had
till I put it down at 80% it's called
the last train to Key West couple people
had recommended it and it's just so good
a bit of historical fiction um I was
just so nap shirt and I can't wait to go
home and finish it I am like so in on
the crown and it's like yeah it's
getting so good I got to the Jackie O
episodes yesterday which were so
interesting and to me like that's the
type of [ __ ] that's like what I love
about the toast it's like celebrity
logistics like little things you didn't
know and just like these little
conversations she had with Jackie O and
like that whole episode was fabulous now
I'm on the episode about Prince Charles
is schooling that's what I was trying to
tell you which I just finished so he
goes to that like terrible like prison
like boarding school for five years
because Prince Phillip is
Oh insane and like the Nazi connection
of like the royal family like will never
not give me chills
I know but they've really expunged it
from anyone in the family who had a sort
of like Nazi connection except Prince
Philip but Prince Philip he wasn't a
Nazi but he lived with his sister and
her husband who was a Nazi and all their
kids who all wore the red armbands
that's oh yeah and like when he went
went to her funeral and like it was
literally like like he was a high
commanding Nazi and like literally it
was like a whole parade with Nazis just
like chilling I don't like Prince Kaleb
like walking down like behind the casket
but like all these [ __ ] Nazis like
you know it's hard to forget that yeah
that that is very killing it was
chilling um but he did end up growing up
at that school so he didn't grow up with
Nazis anymore because very sadly the
Nazis all died in that plane crash I was
I was devastated
so he like he is technically like he can
wash his hands of the Nazi isms because
like his dad was neglectful and made him
live with his sister who happened to be
a Nazi and like that was his primary
guardian and like she was a Nazi like it
was there was he really had nowhere else
to go so when they you know thankfully
died he had to live at that school which
was obviously like a mean boarding
school but it was better than growing up
with [ __ ] Nazis yeah and also about
that boarding school like it's
definitely a crazy school but he really
loved it right it became like family for
him yeah it was you know they definitely
had like a harsh way of teaching kids
and kids but it's not forever it found
it to be beneficial it's definitely it's
not for the faint of heart and that is
also now that we're like learning so
much more about Charles I'm I feel like
I'm fairly certain that he probably
won't be king so this is like the big
conversation just for amongst Royalists
um I don't know how they can skip over
him it's never really been done well
here are the reasons why I think that he
should be skipped over one he's like
super old like what would be the point
to he's like tainted because he is
remarried to someone who was divorced
right doesn't that make his divorce yeah
but it doesn't count it's the person who
is divorced from died remember that's
like a rule in in sure
that's why he could swipe Princess
Margaret couldn't marry Peter Townsend
because his wife was still alive got it
so I feel like that and he's just from
what I know about him like from being in
the public eye and now watching he's
just like ill-equipped
yeah he's ill-equipped he's not like our
girl the queen who is very royal and
stately and above the fray he's very
much in the mix and makes his positions
about a lot of things known and that's
just not the Royal behave we're doing
but it's not the Royal way of doing
things and I feel like because Queen
Elizabeth has had like such a successful
long reign they might want to continue
that and when in if William becomes king
like he will be young he will be the
same age like when when Elizabeth
started so it'll be like back-to-back
like long hopefully triumphant reigns
yeah I agree I think all the reasons are
there for them to skip over him I just
don't know how they can do that it's not
really a thing that's done right um
unless he did something terrible like
King George's brother like be a Nazi and
then leave abdicate for life she loves
to abdicate because he fell in love with
the divorced woman that's what I'm
saying like they're only reasons they
could find a loophole in like the whole
system to give the throne up for Charles
yeah I mean I would love to see that
yeah but once I some royal expert said
that's just not even a possibility and
so to happen and so I've kind of moved
on from so what I'm taking away from the
crown which is probably two things I'm
taking away that I'm actually really
enjoying it's like one it is nice to
watch things that like expand my
worldview and like make me understand
history a little bit more and to like
I'm very familiar with the royal family
but I'm not always familiar with how
they're all connected like who is who
who who's who was whose son who was
whose brother and so now just watching
it starting with Elizabeth Andrew was
born and I'm like Jeffrey Epstein Andrew
princess Prince Andrew oh that's Charles
his brother like just putting all the
connecting all the dots is actually
really helpful for me as someone who
just like is interested in the royal
family and talks about them a lot and my
platform understanding how they're all
connected familiarly is super important
I think and do you feel like watching
the crown and understanding the
institution that is the royal family
makes you feel differently about Harry
and Meghan well yes obviously now it's
like wow what they did was so
disgraceful but at the same time it's
like this life is so and you can't
choose it like you are born into it and
obviously people see like the glitz and
the
and the butler's which by the way like
what I've also taken away from the crown
is that like I need to be the queen
because like just having all these
Butler's who like get you dressed and
like bring you food and like literally
do everything for you open all the doors
like I need that level of service in my
life she is on like 24/7 from the moment
she wakes up like she doesn't just get
to like lay in bed and watch TV with
your Butler bringing her croissants no
it doesn't work like that like she has
to get up put on her suit carry her
purse and her little heels walk down the
hall get to work and doing paperwork and
then she gets a croissant well that's
the thing is like so what what I feel
like the crown has opened my eyes to is
like royal life is obviously not what
you think it is it's it's this it's
quite mundane it's mundane and it is
this burden to like not be able to like
live your true life and like having to
always be in like the way that people
receive receive you because it's
supposed to be like this aspirational
like family when meanwhile they're all
like dying on the inside like they
they're miserable
so for Harry and Megan it's like but
also then I also feel like why does the
crown just like let up sometimes like
even with Princess Margaret it's like
she's not gonna be queen like let her
marry whoever the [ __ ] she wants like
she's quote-unquote irrelevant like who
cares but I get that it's like the
integrity of the crown the integrity of
the crown the integrity of the crown but
so with Harry it was like he's not gonna
be king let him marry whoever he wants
and he did and look what happened so
it's I'm on both sides where I'm like
I'm very much like a like a champion of
the crown and the keeping the integrity
while also moving into the modern era
and I think that Megan Markel was a
sensational choice um because she was
divorced and because it's a completely
white family like I'm it sends a bad
message it's like okay look we progress
look what happened yeah the family is
broken so I don't know I don't know how
I feel I do hope that they get to that I
mean I don't know if they'll get to
Megan but I hope they get to like Diana
I don't think they're gonna get to Megan
they just said I think we're gonna get
two more seasons because just some news
came out that they're gonna do a season
six Diana will be next season got it um
they've already cast her and that'll be
exciting when the Kristen Stewart Diana
movie comes out is so many course it's
all snow-white all over again and
Kristen Stewart's right in the middle of
it I mean I could use like a little bit
of like William and Kate yeah well you
know what maybe maybe that's how though
and it like um because he's the Kitty's
the next king and like that's the next
crown and then maybe in a hundred years
like Netflix will do or at fifty years
next well Netflix will do like the crown
yeah
starting with Williams beginning of his
reign probably not but I think that
would be actually be a great way to end
it like assuring and who will be the new
king but you know what it's just so
interesting with all the marriages
because what I find so interesting it's
not like whenever anyone gets married
it's like the crown is never really
happy about it like I remember even in
modern times with Kate Middleton like
she was technically a commoner never was
like she's a commoner she's a commoner
Chicana but when Queen Elizabeth married
a prince
Phillip whose grandmother was Queen
Victoria like it was a huge problem yeah
and it wasn't a problem because he had
like weird Nazi connections was a
problem because they think he was good
enough yeah which is so crazy right and
then Princess Martinez but now you're
marrying a photographer who's in engaged
in some sort of trouble right and they
were right about Prince Elle's like not
being good enough but he learned like
eventually he did and now I'm at the
point where it's like we're not talking
about their marriage anymore like he's
pretty much settled he's on board he's
on board but he's still not right like
he's he's so engulfed in his own like
self selfishness that he's like always
like threatening his marriage where he
knows they can't get excuse me bless you
he knows that they can't get divorced
like with the school thing he was like
you know he's really stubborn and like
he and he pulls the one card that he has
yeah being a husband yeah and he like
just is so desperate for some sort of
power in his marriage because like he's
has done most powerful woman in the
world and he just like feels the need to
constantly like flex but you know what
eventually at least this is how I felt
and I don't remember the intricacies of
every episode but I do feel like
eventually he does become like a good a
better husband he stops like
philandering and just looking for
something that he's never gonna have yes
no he's not philandering anymore no but
he starts to become like someone that
she can actually like go to for advice
and I and I think like actually a smart
person and that's what he wanted he just
wanted to be like included as a dummy
and running around by his friend Michael
but now like in the most recent season I
feel like she would go to him first up
and he always had like a firm and legit
perspective I don't know she always went
with his advice but it was always
interesting to hear from him yeah so
yeah it's just I feel like I'm having
just like interesting conversations
about the crown and that's the type of
content that I like to consume that
merely stimulates my brain I think for a
while I intentionally only watch stupid
[ __ ] and [ __ ] I'd seen a million times
because I just was too anxious about the
idea like opening myself up to new TV
shows it sounds so stupid
but I'm really enjoying the crown and I
had a dream about the Queen and I'm just
a queen I'm a disgrace Queen and she's
the real Queen yeah speaking of your
loan for something fabulous to watch
head over to my Instagram stories to
find some links for where to watch my
comedy special so many people watch it I
can't bleep people are still watching it
like that's what's crazy it's like
you're really something in like a day
everyone's like listen to it it feels
these days
no but that's why we have to just keep
saying on this show that if you haven't
watched it yet like you are robbing
yourself of a wonderful hour and 45
minutes and it's pretty long I know
Claudia's there were 12 minutes but
sorry I know that you are very critical
of other people right and that's why I
wouldn't be more than an hour and a half
right but not less than that either yes
yes um it's really quite fabulous thank
you you can head over my Instagram story
I have a highlight called disgraced
Queen which is links to all the places
you could stream rent by listen to the
audio or watch the video so just check
it out and thank you guys so much for
all the support and that's all she wrote
right um thank you guys yes to the
morning toast Imani a morning show where
we go on youtube monday through friday
at a certain time we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that Spotify iTunes stitcher
Public Radio IR radio cashbox all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much have a great day goodbye
goodbye
[Music]